y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida vamos a iniciar hoy
en eeuu que anunció inversiones privadas
para reducir la migración desde
centroamérica o la valentina buenas
noches pues es la vicepresidencia de ese
país es dijo haber reunido compromisos
de inversión corporativa que serán
destinados a abordar algunos de los
factores económicos que justamente
impulsan esa migración desde
centroamérica a 1.200 millones de
dólares que se habían comprometido en
diciembre se sumaron ahora a empresas
como la franquicia de pagos visas o la
empresa de ropa gap con destinaciones
adicionales por mil 900 millones de
dólares y lo que harán es crear puestos
de trabajo ampliar el acceso a internet
y bancarizar a más ciudadanos para que
mejoren sus condiciones de vida y no
tengan la necesidad de migrar hacia eeuu
este será también uno de los platos
fuertes de la participación del
presidente yo wyden en la cumbre de las
américas de esta semana en los ángeles
ahora hablamos del banco mundial que
presentó sus nuevas acciones para este
año que países mejoran y cuáles empeoran
en la región bueno primero pues hay que
decir que la institución financiera
redujo las perspectivas en general de
crecimiento mundial hasta el 2,9 por
ciento este año como consecuencia desde
luego de la guerra en ucrania los altos
precios y los problemas en las cadenas
de suministros para américa latina y el
caribe la proyección quedó casi intacta
frente al deporte previo de enero y se
prevé un crecimiento del 2,5 por ciento
ahora sí vamos a analizar por países las
perspectivas son más optimistas para
colombia argentina bolivia ecuador y
brasil que son grandes también
exportadores muchos de ellos
exportadores de commodities pero chile
perú y sobre todo méxico han empeorado
sus previsiones frente a enero y vamos a
hablar de uno de ellos de mexico el
banco mundial explica que sus políticas
monetarias restrictivas su alta
inflación también su incertidumbre
política y la desaceleración en eeuu van
a impactar con fuerza en su economía nos
estaremos muy pendientes de lo que
ocurra con estos países
en reunión del consejo y al parlamento
europeo el tema de hoy fue laboral si
fue laboral y además lo que veíamos en
el noticiero sobre los cargadores quiero
decirle que apple no va a estar muy
contento con esta decisión y apele
tienen también bastante
investigaciones abiertas en la unión
europea' ahora sí pues se llegaron a un
acuerdo entonces en la unión europea
para establecer reglas comunes para
definir el salario mínimo no
necesariamente esto significa que habrá
una unificación de montos en los 27
países que conforman el bloque porque
las brechas son inmensas sino que por lo
menos tengan los mismos criterios para
definir si el ingreso es adecuado es
suficiente y también es digno para los
ciudadanos también se llevó a un acuerdo
para exigir a las empresas que el 40 por
ciento de los puestos directivos sean
ocupados por mujeres lo que se pretende
es reducir la desigualdad salarial que
hace que hoy en día países como
luxemburgo tengan un salario mínimo de
más de 2.200 euros y bulgaria de menos
de 350 ahora este proyecto pasa a
votaciones formales en el consejo y el
parlamento y tendrá dos años para ser
implementado pero bueno tenemos que
suponer que esta diferencia en el
salario mínimo también tiene que ver con
los costos de vida en el país realmente
en luxemburgo es bastante mucho más alto
que en bulgaria daniela eeuu cambió el
discurso frente a los impactos de la
inflación sí señora pues la secretaría
del tesoro janet yellen compareció ante
el comité de finanzas del senado en
donde terminó a dar un giro al discurso
que venían manejando el gobierno y la
reserva federal sobre la inflación y es
que decían que la alta inflación era un
fenómeno pasajero ahora reconocen que
llegó para quedarse y no solamente por
la guerra en ucrania sino que también
hay un aspecto particular que les
preocupa que viene desde la pandemia
escuchemos
creo que alrededor de un tercio de la
inflación de eeuu corresponde a
automóviles nuevos y usados y los
fabricantes se han visto obligados a
reducir la producción de automóviles
cuando enfrentaban una demanda
absolutamente récord de esos vehículos o
puesto número uno por situation wear nos
encontramos en una situación casi
inimaginable en la que la pandemia en
una explosión de la demanda de chips a
nivel mundial ya que las personas
migraron cada vez más hacia el trabajo
digital y nuestras fábricas de
automóviles resultaron incapaces de
adquirir chicos enable y jet shops y
cerramos este espacio de economía con
los indicadores económicos
valentina wall street del cerro con
ganancias a pesar de la caída de las
acciones de grandes minoristas como wal
mart y home depot esto después de que
target anunciará un plan para deshacerse
de inventarios y cancelar pedidos y esto
va a afectar sus resultados y también
tuvo su acción el día de hoy en américa
latina méxico cortó una racha de
sensaciones negativas y la bolsa
argentina subió esto en medio de la
polémica por el impuesto extraordinario
que quiere introducir el gobierno a las
ganancias inesperadas por la guerra en
un gran eso para las compañías daniela
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica ya continuamos aquí en directo
américa con director
[Música]